se há um ano alguém tivesse me falado
que eu passaria dias dormindo no chão
sem tomar banho
trabalhando de sol a sol para construir
uma casa no aterro sanitário e acham que
será pouco provável
e se essa pessoa ainda me dissesse que
eu gostar tanto dessa experiência a
ponto de contar os dias para a próxima
construção
eu realmente não acreditaria nela no
entanto eu estou aqui hoje esperando
ansiosamente pela minha quarta
construção que vai começar exatamente 15
dias
em outubro do ano passado meu colégio
santo inácio fez uma parceria com o teto
para levar 17 alunos e três professores
para construir em duas casas com
famílias vivendo em uma comunidade no
rio de janeiro
eu nunca tinha ouvido falar no teto
então fui me informar e descobrir que o
teto é uma organização que tem a
seguinte missão trabalhar sem descanso
em comunidade precários para superar a
extrema pobreza por meio da ação
conjunta entre seus moradores e jovens
voluntários promovendo o desenvolvimento
comunitário denunciando a situação na
qual vivem milhões de pessoas nessas
comunidades mais precárias e advogando
por políticas sociais
eu já vinha participando de algumas
atividades de voluntariado no colégio ea
oportunidade de construir uma casa me
chamou bastante atenção é o colégio fez
uma um sorteio entre os alunos estão
interessados em participar mas
infelizmente eu fiquei de fora só que
duas semanas antes da construção eu
recebi a notícia que o menino tinha
quebrado a perna e que eu ia no lugar
dele eu ainda não sabia mas no momento
que o rodrigo quebrou a perna a minha
vida estava prestes a mudar pra sempre e
agora ele já está recuperado eu posso
confessar que você ternamente grato por
ele ter quebrado a perna exatamente
naquela semana
a minha primeira construção foi jardim
gramacho uma comunidade que se formou no
que já foi o maior aterro sanitário da
américa latina as pessoas e os
estabelecendo lá para trabalhar na
reciclagem e com o fechamento desse
aterro
muitas famílias ficaram sem renda e sem
outro conhecimento que não o trabalho
com lixo muitas casas lá
um barraco de madeirite que não protege
as pessoas de bichos e muito menos da
chuva é nós passamos três dias na
comunidade
dormimos em uma escola próxima comemos
com as famílias as refeições que eles
mesmo que preparavam e não tomamos banho
que a gente não quer gastar água que já
é escassa na comunidade
foram três dias trabalhando de sol a sol
deitando na lama cavando buracos
carregando painéis e conhecendo uma
realidade completamente diferente da
minha
no final do terceiro dia quando nós não
seguramos a casa com a família
eu estava exausta com bolhas nas mãos
mas com a sensação de que eu tinha tido
a melhor experiência da minha vida
naquele momento eu ainda não consegui
entender o que estava acontecendo na
minha cabeça era uma sensação de que
alguma coisa tinha mudado um bem estar
que foi difícil até de explicar
considerando o meu estado físico
quando voltei pra casa eu comecei a
enxergar tudo de um jeito diferente
eu percebi o quanto a gente baliza
coisas como poder beber água potável ter
um teto sobre as nossas cabeças ou até
mesmo não tenho que me preocupar com
animais entrando na nossa casa no meio
da noite quando voltei pra casa eu me vi
uma pessoa mais paciente - preocupada
com pequenos problemas e mais satisfeito
de uma maneira geral eu passei a
valorizar cada noite de sono que eu
tinha minha cama confortável sabendo que
a poucos quilômetros de mim
há pessoas que sonham com isso todos os
dias eu comecei a olhar em volta dos
lugares que eu freqüento nos
restaurantes no clube
na minha escola eu entendi que o que nos
separa dos moradores de jardim gramacho
é simplesmente a sorte eu não tenho uma
vida tranquila e confortável porque eu
mereço mas simplesmente porque eu tive a
sorte ao meu favor
ficou muito claro pra mim que ninguém
deve depender da sorte para ter uma vida
digna
então eu tive a certeza de que não ia
parar na primeira construção desde
outubro eu já participei de outras duas
nas comunidades de vila beira mar e
canal do anil
foram dias de muito trabalho
esforço e muito cansaço construindo as
casas da carol do victor a do pedro
paulo a do da lidiane da ajuda mas o que
eu levei de volta das construções foram
lembranças das marteladas que eu dei ou
dos buracos que eu cavei o trabalho
físico
lado a lado com as pessoas que moram
nessas comunidades nos proporciona uma
interação espontânea de igual para igual
gera um diálogo profundo um entendimento
que muitas vezes até dispensa palavras
por isso muito mais que os calos nas
mãos
hoje porém a gente fez o que eu levei de
volta das construções foram a imagem do
victor que era tão tira a vontade de não
querer tirar foto com a gente entrou em
sua nova casa com a filha no colo
fazendo uma dancinha de comemoração
o pedro paulo é a figura que não parava
de reclamar mas fazia tudo o que
precisava ser feito e ainda do dinheiro
de três anos entrou em sua nova casa com
um sorriso no rosto
falando em minha casa e posando para a
foto naqueles momentos eu experimentei
uma sensação muito forte de ser feliz
através da felicidade do outro essas
famílias agora têm um teto para se
proteger da chuva
mas esse é apenas o primeiro passo para
que elas tenham uma vida mais digna
ainda muito pela frente para elas e para
os outros bilhões de pessoas no mundo
que vivem uma situação parecida no
brasil são 28 milhões de pessoas vivendo
em situação de pobreza
esse é o número que impressiona bastante
e não era exatamente novidade pra mim
mas os números puros nos mobilizam
trabalhar ombro a ombro com essas
famílias
escutar suas histórias de sua própria
voz e viver suas vidas
mesmo que por poucos dias me ajudou a
transformar os números e as estatísticas
em nomes e rostos me mostrou o
verdadeiro significado da empatia
empatia que leva você em direção ao
outro quando você pensa nas pessoas como
uma massa
você acha que não pode fazer nada porque
o problema muito grande e vocês on
mas mesmo que perto desse número final o
seu trabalho parece uma gota no oceano
se você fizer a diferença na vida de uma
família
de uma só pessoa já vai ter valido a
pena a experiência nas constituições me
ajudou a afastar o meu pensamento dos
números e aproximá los das pessoas no
trabalho do teto
o morador é sempre protagonista
nós queremos que eles meios pensem em
dos problemas das comunidades que vão
muito além da moradia e elabora as
soluções
aí é elaborar soluções o nós voluntários
somos apenas facilitadores desse
processo
nós promovemos discussões e debates
entre eles e auxiliamos na implantação
de soluções
atualmente nas comunidades do rio de
janeiro nós além das moradias
nós estamos desenvolvendo o projeto de
coleta de lixo construção de uma
biblioteca comunitária é implantação de
cisternas e entre outros
nós percebemos que quando uma família
participa de uma construção
ela dá o primeiro passo em direção a uma
vida mais digna ter um teto traz
benefícios físicos e morais poder dormir
à noite com o mínimo de segurança poder
dizer que tem uma casa e isso fortalece
aquelas pessoas de várias maneiras e faz
com que eles passem a querer mais e a
lutar com mais propriedade pela por
aquilo que eles precisam e querem ter
que ser uma família impactadas pela
construção de sua nova casa sofre
mudanças profundas
eles passam a criar expectativas para as
suas vidas se fortalecem como cidadãos
começam a deixar para trás o ciclo da
desesperança e passa uma funcionava como
um farol para a sua comunidade sinalizam
no caminho diferente daquele que todos
pensavam estar destinados a seguir da
mesma forma que cada voluntário que se
envolve com esse trabalho também é
profundamente impactado
quando voltei da minha primeira
constituição eu me tornei uma voluntária
fixa do teto no rio de janeiro
freqüentando as reuniões semanais da
equipe de colégios
somos nós que fazemos a parceria entre o
teto e as escolas pensão implementando
ações que possam envolver os alunos com
o nosso trabalho
é a promoção da consciência e ação
social
e essas atividades que nós realizamos
com os alunos do ensino médio
só uma ferramenta para a formação de
jovens voluntários críticos e proativos
que tenham consciência da realidade do
país em que eles vivem
essa conscientização também acontece
durante as construções para cada uma
delas estabelecendo um tema que vai
servir de base para as atividades e
dinâmicas que nós realizamos todos os
dias de manhã e de noite
temas como a sociedade patriarcal a
favela como parte da cidade ou às
relações que formam o coletivo são fonte
de discussões e reflexões entre todos os
moradores e voluntários
essa é uma parte muito importante das
construções por que ter a oportunidade
de refletir antes e depois da jornada
traz ainda mais significado para o nosso
trabalho me disse que aquele que tem um
porquê para viver pode suportar qualquer
como tomar decisões é uma das situações
mais difíceis da vida principalmente
quando a gente é jovem
são tantas decisões importantes que a
gente tem que tomar
e isso muitas vezes nos paralisa e deixa
sem rumo mas quando se tem um objetivo a
escolha se tornam mais fáceis porque seu
objetivo maior vai sempre valorizando
cada decisão que você tomar
eu nunca tinha me visto especialmente
sem um era só uma adolescente normal
vivendo uma vida normal eu tinha
objetivos e sonhos de uma forma normal
eu trabalhava para alcançá los mas
quando conheci o voluntariado e eu
descobri a diferença entre ter um
objetivo e ter uma causa quando você
encontra e abraça uma causa para além de
se você desconstrói e reconstrói toda a
sua cadeia de pensamentos você possa
entender que a felicidade sucesso
poderia ter significado completamente
diferentes e você passa a acreditar que
realmente pode mudar muito
o voluntário de cada vez uma família de
cada vez que fazemos para nós mesmos
morre conosco que fazemos pelos outros e
pelo mundo permanece e é imortal e você
o que vai fazer hoje para mudar o mundo
obrigado